so our brain continues to produce
dopamine all the time bleeping sounds of
our pc email coming in watching youtube
whatsapp the phone ringing our rooms are
basically like skinner boxes a bed a tv
a fridge nothing to do but to press the
lever for the drugs from analog back in
dopamine nation but sometimes our
addictions can go too far going crazy
watching tv for hours or binging on our
favorite foods that's what i want to
talk about a little bit this week doing
a dopamine detox so i was inspired after
the book by annalem beck on dopamine
nation and she talks about the dangers
of these dopamine inducing modern
appliances such as the internet but also
our easy availability to food and
different drugs and that this constant
dopamine rush is kind of disturbing our
natural ability to make dopamine in
normal situations because she states
when we are consuming high dopamine
rewards we lose the ability to take joy
in ordinary pleasures and after reading
the book of the dopamine nation i kind
of decided that i wanted to look at some
of my own habits and see
where i am going a little bit too far in
inducing dopamine so for example i have
the tendency when i'm really stressed to
binge watch a lot of netflix shows or to
read some of my favorite novels
throughout the evening and although i
don't think these are the worst habits i
do think i could be a little bit more
mindful of the bad habits that i have
and that's why after this book i have
conducted a list of five tips that if
you want to do a little dopamine detox
with me could probably help you reset
your normal dopamine homeostasis
so my first tip is to remove all the
distractions in your environment such to
make your environment as productive as
possible for your dopamine detox so for
example you can think of blocking
certain websites such as youtube or
netflix during certain hours of the day
or putting your phone on airplay mode or
removing it a little bit also if you
have the tendency to snack a lot on
sugary foods to remove these from your
environment such that you can go into
this dopamine detox as naturally as
possible the second tip i would give is
to also have a certain time slot in the
week where you try to remove all these
unnatural dopamine inducers as much as
possible so for example you can think of
the weekend and make you keep your
weekends media free or phone free and if
this is a little bit too much or you
find this a little bit too hard you can
also just pick a few hours of the day
for example in the evening or in the
mornings that you don't use any media at
all and just kind of see how this
affects you because in the book by anna
lambert the dopamine nation she does
talk about a little bit the anxiety we
usually feel when dopamine inducing
things or behaviors are removed from our
system so if you feel a little bit
anxious the first week just try to kind
of be mindful of that and just let it
sit or try to journal about it a little
bit because getting closer to our
emotions is usually one of the ways that
we can alleviate some of the bad habits
that we have formed the third tip i
would give is to get dopamine from
certain behaviors that are related to
pain so in the book she talks about
certain behaviors that are related to
pain or adversity that actually
increases dopamine naturally in our
system as well so one of the most well
known right now is this so-called cold
showers so wim hof discusses this
extensively in his book and he kind of
goes into the benefits of taking cold
showers but if you're really adverse to
cold showers like i am there are
different ways to get dopamine for more
pain inducing behaviors so one of the
other ones is exercise or intermittent
fasting and i think both of these are
pretty interesting because they kind of
put your body under a little bit of
stress and we know from research that a
little bit of stress can actually be
good for animals and also humans to
increase longevity so for example dr
uberman talks about this in his podcast
extensively of what the effects are of
intermittent fasting on the brain and
the body but basically it comes down to
hermesis and hormesis is this phenomenon
where adaptive responses of biological
systems to moderate environmental or
self-imposed challenges or stress
through which the system improves its
functionality and or tolerance to more
severe challenges or you can just say
there's no growth without pain this is
kind of the conclusion of that but i do
think this is a really interesting
mechanism and something you can
experiment with as well so the fourth
tip i would give is if you have some
habits that are a little bit bad to swap
them with better habits so for example
if you have the habit of snacking during
your studies to try to replace your
snacks with some healthier snacks or if
you have the habit of watching a lot of
tv to try to watch tv in another
language such that it may help your
language studies and i think by being a
little bit less strict on ourself and
just just gently swapping in some better
habits this is sometimes a little easier
than to totally remove all the bad
habits altogether and the last advice i
would give is to try to have in the year
a certain week or even a month that you
totally abstain from certain behaviors
that you deem negative because in the
book dopamine nation and liberte talks
about that if we want to reset the
reward pathway we have to abstain from
certain behaviors for about a month at
least
so i think this is in general really
hard but for example if you have a phone
addiction it would be good to see if you
have a period in a year where you could
remove your phone from your life for a
longer period of time and i think by
doing this you can really get deep down
into the root of what exactly is causing
some of the addictive behaviors you have
and i do think this is one of the
hardest challenges and that's why i
would recommend to do it for example in
the summer when we just have naturally a
little bit more free time so yeah these
were the tips i have for today but i
would highly recommend you to read the
book dopamine nation i think she talks
about a lot of interesting patients she
had and some of their addictions which
are really shocking but also sometimes
recognizable for myself as well so if
you have any tips and tricks for me i
would love to hear them so put them down
in the comments below and i also made a
video about motivation if you lack some
motivation in 2022 which i think is
really logical and otherwise see you
next week bye